so uh
there's no single aikido
regardless of
herd mentalities and modern illusions
where you have group over individuals
there's no single idea
regardless of that discourse we are
like the days of old where you didn't
study john
you went and studied with that master
you studied at
that mountain in that
temple with that master
john is something for
academics
so there's no single aikido then there's
no single
ukemi and you can reverse
engineer by how uke
what the moves are for naga
okay um
we have a few people come out so
and you're going to do a back break ball
looking this way
going back
please look that way there you go
there is a point where it goes forward
but then there's a point where it goes
backwards
forward
[Music]
okay
same thing
less do you think stay this way
and go back now i want you to make it go
back
this is closer to the last example now i
want you to watch what happens
when she brings her center back
to her head what happens to her head
go the head comes forward
uh let's look at some extreme examples
so
this is where i go here
sit down the head comes
way full every time the center goes back
the head comes forward to lower myself
so i go
by that design
you would be able to tell that the nage
the nagiwaza does not expect the person
to come forward
they expect the person to go backwards
so can you do that last version
yes
you got to do the other
if he tries to do that and i expecting
him to go
forward he comes forward
it's impossible you can't you can't do
it
so you know by default by how the uket
looks in their chemi what the assumption
is for naginwasa
okay there's another assumption
in that last version so
as he goes down
he's going straight back his
head go is
on the line of attack the entire time
okay and the resolution is by him
staying ahead of the line of attack
that's
problematic if he was supposed to be
going forward he can't stay ahead of it
you see well if my assumption is that
i'm pushing him backwards then he'll he
can sort of stay ahead of it
it's kind of risky because if i
overpower him or over
accelerate him he's going to hit his
head
because it's on the line of attack okay
um but the assumption here from the
noggin was uh
let's do coquiho and you have to do that
other version okay
is that the throw is backwards
straight that the line is this way
if the technique rotates
it's going to go this way and he trying
to do
that other one can't do the other one
so there is this interdependency between
ukis architecture
and nagin's architecture and you can
reverse engineer the two
okay um
what we do is we have
when a person is going to take a new
kemi towards the rear
towards her back in a supine
position
we expect them to be going forward
not backwards person that can go
backwards
is the person that can run out of the
technique so he's coming in
and i'm gonna make him go straight
backwards and instead of lowering
yourself
use my acceleration to just take it out
of the technique
okay so and the reason that he's
able to do that is because his base of
support
is never itself being deconstructed
or addressed only his line of gravity
is being addressed okay so in other
words
if he leaves if he leaves his feet still
then i can accelerate his line of
gravity out
and get something like that going but
there was nothing
addressing his base of support
secondly we want to address the base of
support
not just the line of gravity so line of
gravity is going to go one way
and basal support is going to go the
other way
then you can't do that as we can
additionally
um when we come in
i am uh not so much
at all interested in acceleration
okay if to accelerate something
i have to admit i have to be able to
press on it
we don't want to press on something like
to press on something
and to have it function in my favor i
have to be stronger than it
and we don't want to do that okay so
we're not going to be acceleration
dependent
because i have to be stronger and
because he can out accelerate whatever
i'm accelerating
okay so we are uh going to
look at a more sound way
of creating a topsy-turvy effect which
we will define
by his head training
orientation with his feet right now
head is towards the ceiling and feet are
towards the floor
and we're going to reverse that where
head is going towards the floor and feet
are just going towards the ceiling
topsy-turvy effect okay and the best way
to do that
is not to turn it straight over itself
because each side is offering resistance
to the other side making it very heavy
what we're going to do is tilt it we're
going to tilt it
you see and then each side starts to
assist the other side as it goes into
the topsy-turvy
bag so his body
can't come forward his head because
he's going to be going forward his
center can't go backwards
center's going to keep going forward and
he can't go straight back
because we're going to rotate him okay
so the ukemi we're going to see
is his head is going to come off the
line
okay so go ahead and do army kimmy his
center is going to stay
up and you're going to see his body
rotate
center boom stays there
and his body rotates okay and that way
uh you can see oh that's the shape of
the arc
of the nagawaza so coming in
and
okay so let's learn how we do this
i'll start at phase one it's down
and we're first going to learn the
pattern okay
so he'll have his left knee facing this
way
and his right knee is a right angle
the back leg is going to mark the
rolling
or the the chemi arm so
his head wants to go in this case
in the direction of the back leg so he
goes backwards and he sees this right
angle to the line of attack
okay i'll do it again
then the next phase for beginners he
stands up
and he's going to drop to kiza so knees
aren't on the ground
and now he does the same angle again
same thing feet are in position kiza
goes back and that angle gets his head
off the line okay but at this point
we're not working with the center
staying forward you see we're allowing
his center
go to stay there it didn't come forward
but it's not going back either
okay so that his head never comes
forward during the whole move
okay because the center never goes back
in the move
all right now we gotta work on getting
the center
um to come up so we're gonna come out of
the stance
and he's in this kind of neutral stance
and he's going the first phase for this
one for standing is the center comes
forward and then this foot is going to
step
back into that right angle and he goes
that way you go
yep
so center is coming forward because the
energy of the throw is going to require
coming forward
but we let a kind of little tuck at the
end
okay but you want to keep it to a
minimum all right you don't want to
start sitting your butt down
so he steps back
okay and then we have uh
the next phase where if you notice
we go down on the ball of the foot not
the instep of the foot
and that's because that's your bracing
[Music]
engine for lowering yourself we don't
lower ourselves like this
which is why there's no sports like that
nobody plays like that there's no
fighting like that there's no
that is the route to a foot injury
okay why does no one get injured
they uh generally because no one's
actually throwing them
they get to lower themselves okay but he
needs to have
the way his foot works to lower and
reconcile the energy
so in this contracting center drill
he's going to go up and he's not going
to
uh bring this back at all and he's going
to land
on him the ball of his foot of his
choosing
again
[Music]
okay got that drill um that gets you
pretty close
to our architectures before you can do
that
we are not really throwing you we're
letting you practice the back breakfall
[Music]
he goes
good okay so you want to get to at least
there and then there's more advanced
versions of this because
we're not going to give him his foot
when we when we do the throw
you're going to see that he won't get
his foot
but his center contraction is what he
uses so
i'm going to take his foot away he
doesn't get his foot but the center part
and the upper body part is the same
but you got to get to at least that
contracting center drill
back find your back foot
okay gotta get there don't let it come
back don't let your head come forward
that's the problem
okay uh how to get up i'll do it
i'll do it okay so uh when we get up
let's
say we're doing the the first standing
one so i go down
and i come up i don't want to give my
back to the
knock i don't want to ever get in that
habit okay
so that's why we also don't do backwards
rolls you're going to give your back to
the noggin
but you can't do a backwards roll
because anything to the supine
had you coming forward you can only do
the backwards roll if you're going that
way
okay so we don't do the backwards roll
um
if he's my person my noggin
i'm going to keep my eyes on him as i go
to do
the lowering one my eyes stay
on him and i'm out
so another drill you could do is add
some walking
step into the foot position go down into
keys though
eyes are on him
on your eye okay um
let's all do those two so let's work
on the contracting center a drill for
the contracting
center so the last phase we did
is he is out and then he finds his back
but all that is up to him it's one thing
to have a contracting center and a
center that is alive
when you're in control what happens when
you're not
in control is you lose consciousness
the center goes weak soft dead
and it's no longer a contracting center
so
this drill is uh one we're
going to do so i'm going to bring him
into that contraction
and then he finds the drill
because the center is being expanded
like a bow
when i let go it's gonna come back and
there'll be a bounce to it
so cool down
they'll just fall right here
okay or a person that
does not yield and release and open
themselves up
starts to use this to accelerate
and they go into the back rainfall like
this go ahead and go
that's not it so he has to open
all the way
[Music]
and then bounce out okay so my drill
from the naga's point of view or the
trainer's point of view
outside the wrist don't strain the grips
10 con i'm going to bounce off the
bottom
loom and enter okay
here we go he keeps his center contract
the whole way it never goes dead it
never gets soft
okay and in that way he is
technically doing the exact same
internal aspects that i'm doing as
noggin okay
his center never goes soft never gets
gooey okay he's just doing the internal
aspects from the inside
not get dozen from the young side okay
now he's going to keep that contracted
center
and go ahead and get up okay without
giving his back
same drill there's going to be a bounce
boom
out gets up locks his body
so when he's getting up uh disconnect
your center together
like that you see his head
the engaged center creates a
relationship between his head and his
feet
so when his head lock your center when
his head goes back
no more than that as soon as your head
moves your feet should move
and the same thing vice versa should be
like that
become a small gap
so that's what he's working on boom he
keeps that engagement
feet bring the head up up he comes
without exposing his back to me same
drill
feet brings the head up there we go
okay here we go